police in Arizona are hunting for a
gunman who killed at least three people
including a forensic psychiatrist who
worked on high-profile murder cases dr.
Steven Pitts who assisted with the
infamous JonBenet Ramsey investigation
was shot and killed last Thursday police
linked the killings with the murders of
two paralegals the next day
Matea V Lal is in Scottsdale where a
fourth homicide may also be connected
Matea good morning well good morning
after four murders in three days the
city is desperate for answers here dr.
Stephen pit was not only well known to
law enforcement officers here but around
the country he helped put a lot of
criminals behind bars so now his murder
is a top priority it's highly unusual
for someone to wake up one morning and
say you know what today's the day I want
to become a serial killer biggest for
decades investigators sought out dr.
Stephen Pitts for his insight into the
mind of a killer now it's his murder
police are trying to solve the 59 year
old forensic psychiatrist was shot
outside his office Thursday by a white
male suspect bald and wearing a dark hat
are we dealing with a serial killer here
we don't believe so we believe that
these shootings were not random
detectives suspect the same gunman
killed two paralegals the next day
Bellary sharp and Laura Anderson at a
loss as 10 miles away one of the women
who was shot in the head managed to
alert a bus driver before she died
officers that arrived on scene quickly
determined that there was a blood trail
and they followed it back to the law
office was it important to the
investigation that she was able to ask
for help because then that leads you to
another victim it did because if she
didn't make it outside of the business
to ask for help we may not have
discovered that crime scene when we did
police say they recovered evidence
linking the three murder victims they're
also trying to determine if
hypnotherapist and life coach Marsha
Levine is the gunman's a fourth victim
the 72 year old was shot dead in his
office Saturday not far from the other
crime scenes dr. Pitts body was found
less than five miles away normally or D
him talking to you about
a murder case not his own J Gooding and
his brothers Scott were Pitt's lifelong
friends Scott a former police officer in
Florida believes Pitt was murdered by
someone linked to one of his cases this
was an ambush
you know they waited for him to come out
and then they calmly walked away and
they did the same thing to those two
women at the law office hundreds of tips
have come in so more officers have been
brought in to chase down those leads and
also to patrol the streets police also
tell me that investigators have
uncovered other potential victims that
could be in danger so they are working
very closely with them to make sure that
they keep them safe John Mireya thanks